Well, the plane began to cross the
Andes Mountains, one of the soldiers came out
and said, gentlemen, put on your seat
belts because the plane is going to dance for
a while and in fact we put on the seat
belts and the plane begins to
shake. And suddenly we felt a well of
gigantic air that we dropped 600 Met at
once
we were left after the accident
among the people who died in the accident
and on that night there were 27 people
alive out of the 45 and I had really never
seen a dead person in my life And suddenly you
find yourself surrounded by  Dead surrounded
by people screaming at 25 gr below zero without
resources of any kind in a world
that we did not know